you fill-ins think you're so smart you
found a way to take down the barrier and
now you're trying to take over auradon
but if you guys have it all figured out
why do you look so scared in the
official d3 trailer we're looking at you
uma and Harry we thought you guys were
fearless pirates but it looks like
there's something out there that's got
you shaking in your boots oh man hearing
that their match because they seriously
look freaked out but what are these two
adventurous pirates so afraid of keep
watching to find out and no one else is
it Audrey whether Audrey plays a hand in
Oregon's destruction or not it's safe to
say that the princess looks super
suspicious sure she might have been seen
taking a hundred-year nap in her bed
throughout the gnudi three trailers but
there's just too much evidence against
Audrey for her to turn out TWiki clean
we also know for a fact that Amanar crew
of pirates want nothing more than to
take down the barrier once and for all
so they're basically the bad guys right
but if that's true why on earth do we
see lumen our first mate Harry looking
like they saw a ghost in the mystery
trailer it just doesn't make sense to
make matters even more confusing we see
uma grabbing at her seashell necklace as
she stares up at the night sky in under
the sea a descendent short story we see
how powerful Emma's necklace really is
it's wearing dizzy and umas voices
blooming out of it
he's wearing my necklace like my
necklace she can control whoever's
wearing the necklace but since you must
the one wearing it in the mystery
trailer we doubt she's controlling
anyone at that given moment if Audrey
does indeed have the scepter it's
possible that she's coming for Emma and
Harry if she's the one who turned the be
case to stone
she might be angry with the Pirates for
helping out their enemies so perhaps
she's using the scepter to fly over the
forest and turn anyone she crosses to
stone
Ouma might be grabbing at her necklace
because it's what helps her transform
into a giant octopus Ouma might be
preparing to fight Audrey or whoever's
out to get her and Harry but
unfortunately it looks like kuma and
Harry are far from the sea which might
stop her from being able to transform
but if Audrey is really chasing the BK's
through the forest and onto the auradon
prep grounds our favorite pirates might
end up being turned into stone like evj
Carlos and Ben but before we go and
blame the entire thing on Audrey let's
look at some other options
is it Celia Celia is a wild card one
that we have no idea how to judge if it
doesn't make money it doesn't make sense
is her motto so you'd think that she'd
want Oregon's economy to keep thriving
after all it's filled with rich suckers
she can fool
Hiro it's me a tall handsome stranger I
already have it looks like Celia is
playing her own game and she might have
something to do with uma and Harry
running scared through the woods
Celia loves reading people there Tarot
but just like her father Celia's cards
have double meanings so what does she
read Mao's Tarot and secretly cast a
spell on her since mal can transform him
into a dragon it's possible that Celia's
magic is preventing mal from seeing
clearly we see mal turn into a dragon
throughout the trailer and we also see
her blasting an enemy with dragon fire
now later says that which could mean
that she was cursed to act like a wild
fire breathing dragon if dragon mal is
on a rampage then omen Harry should
definitely be scared this is especially
true of Ouma betrayed mal or tricked her
into trusting her throughout the three
cool is it now now
one of the good guys but she does have a
bad reputation while she might be king
vents fiance she's also Maleficent's
daughter which makes her sort of
unpredictable
the last thing mal once is to hurt
someone but that could quickly change if
everyone she loves gets turned to stone
or put to sleep there are a few reasons
why luma and Harry might be running
through the woods while glancing up at
the night sky but they don't all have to
be bad descendants fans are hoping that
Emma and mal will become friends again
in d3 and if this is the case Emma might
be tracking now to stop her from doing
something she regrets if Mouse need for
vengeance is too strong she might end up
harming audrey beyond repair which is
something she would surely regret so
maybe who man Harry were with now when
she transformed and are tracking her
down to talk her out of her current
state the tables will definitely turn if
Ouma tries to get now to remember that
she's good but there's also a another
possibility
what if luma and her crew of pirates are
actually responsible for the sleep spell
and the stone spell what if the trick
mal and her crew into trusting them only
to betray now when she needs them the
most if this is the case mal would turn
into her dragon self in a flash and go
on a pirate hunt in no time seeing your
friends and fiance get turned to stone
and being unable to help them is more
than enough motive to do something hasty
we just hope that bloom and here you are
able to get themselves out of this
sticky situation because well we happen
to think that they're misunderstood
pirates who are fundamentally good since
there's nothing scarier than a
fire-breathing dragon it would make
total sense for Ouma and Harry to be
gazing up at mal in a state of total
fright what do you guys think our Ummah
and Harry running for their lives or
trying to stop Mau from making a huge
mistake sound off in the comments
section
for more videos about your favorite
descendants characters subscribe to the
things and be sure to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching see
you soon
[Music]